-The governor of Texas
threatened
to arrest Democratic lawmakers
who fled the state
to block a Draconian new
voter suppression law designed
to keep Republicans in power.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
I'm sure I don't have
to remind you
that the 2020 election results
were, for the most part,
very bad for Republicans.
Yes, they won back seats
in the House,
but they lost the popular vote
by seven million to a Democrat
who got the most votes
in American history;
they lost the Electoral College
in a landslide;
and they even lost
several states
that were historically red,
like Georgia and Arizona,
where they also lost
all four Senate seats.
In fact, Biden,
his win in Georgia
was confirmed so many times,
he turned it into a joke
when he was campaigning there
for the Democratic
Senate candidates.
-Thank you for standing strong
to make sure
your voices were heard,
your votes were counted
and counted
and counted again!
[ Laughter ]
I'm starting to feel like
I won Georgia three times.
[ Horns blaring ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-One of the few things I'll miss
about COVID-era politics
is the drive-in rallies.
It's the only time in history
we'll be able to look back
and ask,
"Was he giving a speech
or crossing against the light?"
I know it was Georgia,
but the sound of honking
just makes it feel
like New York,
like he should've been up there
with the Times Square Spider-Man
and a cigarette-smoking
cockroach.
[ Smoker's voice ]
Can you believe
this Mets bullpen?
They blew a five-run lead
against the Pirates!
[ Laughter ]
What do you mean, I can't vote
because I'm a cockroach?
I have a valid ID.
[ Laughter ]
It was like that stage is
in the middle of 42nd Street
during rush hour traffic.
[ As Biden ]
I won Georgia three times.
[ New York accent ]
I don't care if you won
Miss America!
I got to get
this ass[bleep] to JFK!
[ Laughter ]
I'm sorry, did you just
call me an ass[bleep]?
[ New York accent ]
Oh, sorry, pal.
I thought you couldn't hear me
over the Taxi TV.
Actually, I'm trying
to turn down
the Taxi TV.
Do you know how to do that?
[ New York accent ]
Hey, I didn't put it there!
Take it up with Cat Greenleaf.
[ Laughter ]
Now, the losses in Georgia
and Arizona
really freaked out Republicans
because it meant
the electoral map was shifting.
States that were traditionally
red were suddenly in play
and the GOP's built-in advantage
in the Electoral College
was eroding.
And that was especially
evident in Texas,
where Trump won
with the smallest margin
for a Republican in 24 years
and Biden got
the largest percentage
of any Democratic candidate
since Jimmy Carter
won the state in 1976.
A fact that surprised me
because everything's bigger
in Texas,
but, according to this photo,
Jimmy Carter is super small.
[ Laughter ]
When I was young and I heard him
referred to as a peanut farmer,
I assumed he farmed peanuts.
But was he a farmer
the size of a peanut?
[ Laughter ]
Don't get me wrong.
He's the best.
I love him.
He's a world-renowned
humanitarian,
human rights activist.
I'm just saying,
judging from this photo,
if he tried to wear
a cowboy hat,
he'd get lost in it.
[ As Carter ]
Rosalynn.
Rosalynn, help.
I'm stuck in the hat.
[ Laughter ]
Again, as a reminder,
I spent the last two weeks
in impression camp.
[ Laughter ]
The point is,
Republicans are terrified
of the possibility
that Democrats could continue
making gains in Texas
and potentially win
the state's electoral votes
in a future
presidential election.
They're not hiding it
or being shy about it.
Here's Texas
Lieutenant Governor Dan Patrick
at the Conservative
Political Action Conference
over the weekend,
telling the crowd
that, if they lose Texas,
they'll lose the entire country.
-In Texas, we are
the last man standing.
There are a lot of conservative
and red states
around the country,
but if we fall, America falls.
The electoral votes of New York,
California and New York
combined together
means we could never elect
a conservative or Republican
to the White House ever again.
I can tell you
that, as lieutenant governor
of this great state
that I'm blessed
and honored to serve,
[ Measuredly ]
we're not ever going
to let that happen.
-Why do these guys
always sound like
overexcited LARPers in the park?
[ English accent ]
By order of the queen,
I shall not allow this heresy.
Calm down, Dan.
You work at Hobby Lobby.
So now, though,
they're just admitting it.
They don't want to lose Texas.
That's what this is all about.
And it's one thing to say,
"We can't lose Texas,
so we have to work on our
message and our policies."
It's another to say,
"We can't lose Texas,
so we're changing the rules.
It's like Subway deciding
between actually using tuna
or calling it toona
and hoping no one notices.
So Texas Republicans are afraid
that, if Democrats make gains,
that they could be locked
out of the White House
for the foreseeable future
and they're desperate
to preserve their political
power in the state
any way they can.
By Patrick's own admission,
GOP success nationally depends
on Republicans keeping control
in Texas,
which is why
Texas Governor Greg Abbott
called a special legislative
session for this month
to pass a series of Draconian
voter suppression laws.
-In Texas, the state legislature
is set to vote this week
on two restrictive
voting bills.
The legislation moved forward
yesterday after a heated debate.
Critics say the measures
unfairly harm Black voters.
-The proposed Texas legislation
includes banning 24-hour
and drive-through voting,
new voter ID requirements
for mail-in ballots,
and expanding the powers
of partisan pollwatchers.
-They want to ban
drive-through voting?
How can you be
against drive-throughs?
The pandemic's been a nightmare,
but one thing it's taught me is
I love not having
to get out of my car.
Last week I had
my appendix removed
and I just left
the engine running.
There's nothing --
[ Laughter ]
One more time.
What was that look?
Great. Great.
[ Laughter ]
Definitely glad
we saw the open cut.
[ Laughter ]
There's nothing more American
than a drive-through.
If you ask me,
not only should you be able
to vote via drive-through,
but, while you're there,
you should also be able
to deposit a check,
get your car washed,
and pick up
a Doritos Locos Taco Supreme.
Doritos Locos Taco Supreme,
made with 100%
all-natural beeeph.
That's beeeph,
with three "E's" and a "ph."
[ Laughter ]
These bills are obviously
designed to make voting harder
and, in particular,
target Black voters.
For example, in an earlier
version of the bill,
it would've implemented a...
And of course they were
targeting Black voters.
What other possible excuse
could they have
for banning voting
on Sunday mornings?
Did they not want to bump up
against everyone's weekly
yoga in the park class?
Because we're all capable
of doing both.
I can get up first thing
in the morning to vote
and then make my way over
to the top of the longmeadow
in time to do child's pose,
Linda!
I know you're mad because I was
five minutes late last week
and I immediately skipped
to cat-cow
and you said, "You have
to start in child's pose.
It represents birth."
And I said,
"Oh, does it, Linda?
[ Laughter ]
Is that what it represents?
Can you tell me more,
since this is my first time
doing yoga, Linda?"
[ Whispering ]
Also,
I know it was you
who farted, Linda.
[ Laughter ]
[ Mouthing
"I know it was you." ]
Republicans ended up
backtracking
and removing that provision
after a backlash,
although their explanation
of what happened was ludicrous.
They claim they weren't
targeting Black voters.
The bill had just been
misprinted and nobody caught it.
-First of all,
11:00 doesn't make
any more sense than 1:00.
Why would banning early voting
before 11:00 am on Sunday
make elections more secure?
You guys afraid the pollworkers
would be too hung over
to detect fraudulent ballots?
"Uh, my vision's super blurry
this morning,
but your ID looks good to me,
Mr. Cockroach."
"Cockroach?!
I'm a cicada, you dunderhead!"
[ Laughter ]
I've never been insulted
in all my life,
which, as you all know,
is 17 years.
Seventeen years.
I'm still in my prime."
"Oh, you got to be 18 to vote."
[ Laughter ]
"How convenient.
This is cicada suppression."
So, that provision
was eventually removed
after a backlash and a walkout
by Texas Democrats,
but, still, it's been clear
from day one
what this is all about.
Republicans admitted it.
They want to hold on
to power in Texas.
And let's also just keep in mind
that Texas is already, arguably,
the most difficult state
to vote in.
Even just registering
to vote is a hassle.
Good Lord!
Sounds like the directions
to one of those board games
you only find in upstate B&Bs.
Anybody up for a game
of -- ooh!
[ Laughter ]
Oh, oh! Hold on!
Wi-Fi's back on.
Ooh! Thank God.
Second, the only situation where
I'd ever want to be deputized is
as the nerdy sidekick
to an outlaw cop played
by Bruce Willis.
And the whole movie,
I'd be begging him
to deputize me and he'd refuse
and then at the end,
there'd be a climactic,
heartwarming moment right before
we storm the bad guys' hideout
where he puts his arm
on my shoulder and says...
[ As Willis ]
Meyers,
I hereby deputize me
to be my deputy.
And, yes, in this movie,
I play myself,
just because it's easier.
I want to have to remember
all my character details,
like a fake name or a job.
I mean, despite
what you might think,
from all my flawless
impressions,
I'm not a professional actor.
[ Laughter ]
It's just a side hobby of mine
that I happen to be
very good at.
Stanislavski begged me
to teach him.
He pleaded with me,
"Please, teach me how you do
your Vince Vaughn impression."
And I'd say...
[ As Vaughn ]
Buddy, buddy, buddy,
you got to relax.
[ Laughter ]
I should admit impressions camp
was a camp you go to
to make you
stop doing impressions.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Clapping ]
-Anyway, the rules in Texas
are already clearly skewed
to the type of voters
Republicans want
to show up to the polls.
For example...
That's really the whole game.
The only way it could be
more obvious is
if they said you can't use
a driver's license,
but you can use a...
So those are the rules
that already exist in Texas.
Now, Republicans want
to make it even worse,
which led Texas Democrats
to flee the state,
in a last-ditch attempt
to stop the bills from passing.
And Fox News criticized
the Democrats
for bringing beer with them.
-Texas state Democrats are
in Washington, D.C. this morning
after leaving the state
in an attempt to block
Republican efforts
to pass a bill
making it harder to vote.
More than 50 House Democrats
got on a plane
and flew to D.C.
on Monday afternoon,
vowing to stay away from Texas
until next month,
so that Republicans
can't vote on anything.
Lawmakers need a quorum --
a certain number
of members present --
in order to vote.
-Fifty-eight Democrats.
Texas Democrats,
are taking a stand
against Republican
voting bills by --
What did they do?
They hopped on a couple
of private jets
and they're flying to D.C.,
but, of course,
first, they have to take
some selfies
to show the folks
what they're doing.
-And they grab the beer.
They did, a case
of Miller Lite, I think.
-Why do Republicans think
it's a gotcha
to point out they had a case
of Miller Lite?
So what, is the GOP
really going after
Texan beer drinkers now?
Everyone knows real Americans
drink vodka, peach Schnapps,
and cranberry juice.
And, yeah,
that's a sex on the beach,
or, as it's known in Texas,
a throwdown at the hoedown.
[ Laughter ]
Now, if you are the Republicans
and you want to dispel
the impression
that this is just
an authoritarian power grab,
the absolute last thing
you'd want to do is threaten
to arrest the Democrats
who fled the state
and, yet, that's exactly
what Abbott did.
-I can and I will continue
to call special session
after special session
after special session,
all the way up
until election next year.
And so if these people want
to be hanging out
wherever they're hanging out
on this taxpayer-paid junket,
they're going to have
to be prepared to do it
for well over a year.
As soon as they come back
into the state of Texas,
they will be arrested,
they will be cabined
inside the Texas Capitol,
until they get their job done.
-A surefire way to make clear
you're the villain
in any situation is
to threaten
to arrest your opponents,
especially in the South.
You sound like Boss Hogg
threatening
to round up those Duke boys.
[ As Hogg ]
Oh, I'm gonna get
them Duke boys!
And, when I do, we're gonna
cabin them inside the Capitol!
But, somehow, another Texas
politician managed
to outdo Abbott, in terms
of pure shamelessness
and I'm sure, by now, you've
probably guessed who it was.
-What you're seeing
the Democrats do here
is a political stunt.
And, you know,
I will say it's ironic
because they were getting
on their private jet
to fly to Washington, D.C.
They almost surely had
to show identification
to get on that jet.
-[ Laughs ]
-And, yet, they're doing
this in a fit
because they don't want
mail-in ballots to be verified.
They don't want the signatures
to be verified.
They don't want
basic integrity steps
to be strengthened
in the state of Texas.
This is, at the end
of the day, politics,
and they need to get back
to doing their jobs.
-It's not ironic that they had
to show ID to get on a plane,
since, unlike voting,
flying on a plane
is not a sacred right protected
by the Constitution.
There's no Article 10
that grants every American
the right to get your elbow
slammed by a drink cart
while the dude across from you
spends 10 minutes trying
to cram a suitcase
into an overhead compartment
that's too small.
Of course,
if Republicans really wanted
to treat flying
the way they treat voting,
then every plane
would be forced to idle
on the tarmac for hours,
while they wait to take off
because there's only
one runway open
and it would be illegal
to serve snacks,
not even SunChips,
which are barely food.
It's like eating
salsa-flavored packing peanuts.
I'm pretty sure there's less
actual food in SunChips
than there are in Subway tuna.
Republicans have come out
and said
what this is really all about --
they don't want to lose Texas
and they're willing
to change the rules
to stop that from happening.
It couldn't be more obvious.
They admitted it.
They just haven't
succeeded yet.
They couldn't pass
these bills the first time.
They might not be able
to pass them this time,
so if they want
to ram them through,
they're going to have to try
at least...
-Three times!
[ Horns blaring ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.